hi there it's 8:35 now um the manager of
the lionesses has come out and stirred
things up a bit frankly because she said
that it's only a matter of time before a
female manager takes full-time charge of
a men's team a shock horror we got a
flavor for full-time female Management
in the men's game when Hannah dingley
took the Reigns at Forest Green in
preseason but should it happen again
well on one side of the debate we've got
football journalist Megan Garber who
says the women's game has grown
massively over the years and the quality
of the coaching has too yes but social
media star and feminism critic Pearl
Davis thinks female appointments are
often more political than earned and
they both join us now good morning to
you Pearl what's wrong with
this well I would say the issue you have
in women's sports as it becomes a
political agenda rather than giving the
best person that is there for the job um
and that is my issues when it becomes
really I don't even think it matters if
it's man or woman I think it is the most
competent person for the job why do we
keep going back to a female manager a
female manager it should just be the
best manager for the job but are you
worried then that there would be token
appointments somebody wanting to make a
point would appoint a female manager
when actually there may be a man around
who would be better yeah I my biggest
issue is when it becomes a political
agenda I don't think as women we need
special handouts or special treatment I
think the best person for the job should
get the job okay Megan what's your take
on
this I totally agree with what Pear's
saying it should go to whoever deserves
the job but I think the people that do
make those appointments will look at it
that way I don't think anyone would
appoint a female just for the sake of it
I mean you look at what Emma Hayes has
done at Chelsea women obviously she's
leaving at the end of the season but
there's no reason why she would not be
able to take charge of a men's team high
up in in you know in the English game or
anywhere in the world because frankly
they get the same coaching you know
they've had access to the same coaching
badges they've got the same skills
expertise the same knowledge so there
shouldn't be a problem with it at all
and lot people seem to be scandalized
don't they I mean what's wrong why are
we even making an issue of it well I I
would say even when women are pulled
they do not prefer female bosses so I
would say women in general struggle in
positions of leadership I don't think
we're naturally good at it um I do think
there are exceptions to the rule as
there are in anything but I do see it
being a political agenda um where they
do not put the best women or they do not
put the best person in the position they
just put women in because they're women
why do you think Pearl that that women
are not natural
leaders um I just think there are things
that women are naturally good at and men
are naturally good at women just tend to
be more agreeable and the trait disagree
agreeability tends to be better for or
men tend to be more that way where women
tend to be more agreeable youve
forgotten Margaret fer and Liz truss and
various other Prime Ministers we well if
you want to look at women in positions
of political power they're actually more
violent and more willing to wage war um
so I actually I actually think that
women do struggle in positions of
political power as well for example your
shortest prime minister ever here was a
woman me what what's your take on
whether women can do women have the same
ability to to lead a team and
particularly I guess when you're talking
about leading a team of of sort of young
and as what a little bit bushy men on a
football
team I mean look we know football has
been a male dominated sport for so long
and that you know that should not be the
case anymore it should be equal but yeah
obviously there's going to be different
challenges when it comes to managing a
men's team team to a women's team yes
you're going to have the you know the
men want to make a name for themselves
individually as well as a team so you
have got to manage those you know those
different attitudes in the team but
there isn't any reason that people like
Serena vman or Emma Hayes or other women
managers there's no reason they can't do
that well I just think if women were so
good at managing a team they would be
better at managing their league I mean
women by and large women's leagues are
not profitable women's leagues do not
make money how are we going to say we
are so great and amazing and awesome at
managing a team when we can't even
manage our own League the majority of
women's leagues really are subsidized by
the
men I think the WSL is creating so much
revenue at the minute and even women's
football in America is you know really
equal to the men's game as well I think
it's not equal at all if you look at
profits it's not even close it's not
equal but in terms of the people that
are watching the game and you know
spending money on the game you know it's
making so much money to what it was you
know even five years ago and I don't see
there's any issue compared to yeah if
it's unprofitable and that's again which
goes back to the problem women's sports
don't tend to make money um if they do
tend to make money it tends to be their
monetizing sexuality in some way but
really by and large women's sports do
not make money and I've really seen this
become a political issue over the years
where the women will cry and whine and
and moan about their pay when
really um by and large women do not
deserve more money because they do not
make what the men make and it becomes a
political issue where we want more money
for Less work and I can't stand it I'm a
female athlete I've been in athletics
for 16 years and I'm really sick of it
becoming a handout off who can get the
most handouts really I think if women
want more money and they want to be in
these positions we wouldn't have to keep
saying we need females in these
positions they would just be in those
positions we need competent people
there's a shortage of competent people
in the world if you are competent you
will get the role and women want special
handouts and treatments and we're even
doing a whole segment on female managers
what does that tell us that we're not
competent enough in general to get the
roles I think obviously we know that the
men's game in football and in other
sports do produce more Revenue but that
doesn't mean the women's game doesn't
produce Revenue you just look at the WSL
in England and the men's grounds are
being used to house the women's games
now and they're out those grounds and
that's just showing how far the game is
coming and I think you know it is a
matter of time before someone breaks
that barrier and will'll manage a men's
team high up by by and large women's
sports operate at a loss the WNBA
operates at a loss um College athletics
Women's College athletics it's
subsidized by male Athletics by and
large women's sports operates at a loss
just because maybe you could point to
one small League somewhere or one League
which really by and large I don't know
five female footballers uh most people
couldn't list you five female
footballers and the only ones you can
really list are the ones that have
become political they make it a
political movement and I think it ruins
the sanctity of the sport because we're
more worried about getting a female
manager then we are in improving the
game isn't but pear it isn't part of the
issue here you say it's you the women
can't manage it it's you know it's not
as profitable as it could be and all the
rest of it but that's that's not down to
the game it's not down to the player all
the managers that's down to the public
not supporting it in the same way and
that is something certainly in the UK
that we are seeing stop to change the
public doesn't support it because it's
not as entertaining I mean do you do you
sir can you list 10 female soccer
players well no but I exactly that's my
point support us support us please I
could that's my point that's it's not
entertaining that's a mute that's a mute
point because I could I could name 10
male players so and here here's the
thing I don't even I don't even watch
soccer but you know really by and large
I I could tell you more male players
than female players because the males
are more entertaining and my thing is
ladies ladies ladies ladies if you want
people to watch be more entertaining and
then you will get more viewers stop
shaming the viewers if a product is not
selling you don't go to the market and
say you bad customers you're just is not
supporting my product you improve the
product so I say improve the level of
the game be more entertaining and then
people will watch okay you're not
willing to do that stop crying to me
about it Megan last word from
you I mean you obviously don't sort of
pay attention to the WSL in England
because that's got its own fan base in
itself and I if I ask those people that
invest their time in the women's game if
they can name five players they can
probably name 50 women's players in the
because they invest their time in it
let's go on the streets of England and
tell them name five female soccer
players and name five male soccer
players well I tell you what you've both
been very entertaining just on this
subject so but we got to wind you up
there but thanks very very much indeed
what